all right well I'm kind of scared to
look at the footage but let's do it
fluffy will be joining us because he's
also in the film
oh my gosh
why are you you're like a little baby
you wake up a lot no I don't
know what's happening so you're like all
the way out boom boom side cross and now
I gotta go to my side even though why is
my arm doing that how do
you sleep like that
staring at me I want to go pee is that
how you wake up yeah that is weird you
get cold at night no not really what do
you do the little because man I'm
comfortable that's comfortable why do
you sleep like this like all spread
eagle thing bro you're literally doing
yoga and meanwhile fluffy just over here
trying to figure out where he fits in